[Music]  is Gisele Bundchen pressuring hubby Tom  Brady to retire from the NFL you know I  just have to say as a wife I'm a little  bit you know it's as you know it's not  the most like um let's say an aggressive  sport right football like he had a  concussion last year I mean he has  concussions pretty much I mean we don't  talk about but he does have concussions  and he's I don't really think it's a  healthy thing for your body to go to  like a gazelle made that big reveal on  Wednesdays at CBS this morning that the  Patriots star has had multiple  concussions  she likes whatever I do now tom has said  he'll play for as long as he feels good  about playing I don't have any plans to  give it up although she told me ten  years ago when I met her I said ten  years from now you know I'm gonna be  done playing and we've been together for  almost nine years and I still say I got  ten more years left so she's look at  that time never changes so I think I  just love it that much